plans and just like we saw in some of  the other games if one side doesn't have  a plan there's no hope no chance of  winning  and there we have Basha  Basho and cheering for Liam Lee yeah all  the way in Hanoi Vietnam staying up all  night I really appreciate everyone who's  watching the show and uh meanwhile in  the game Lavon has tried to make a  winning attempt he's given up the F3  Pawn you can see why he's done he  grabbed the horn but this looks bad oh  now he's gonna lose his Queen and he's  smiling about it and it's that's a good  way to lose just smile and resign  yeah he knows it draws the same as a  loss unfortunately wherever you put the  white king after a couple of tracks the  black Rook will win the White Queen  um just a couple of simple checks  eventually The Rook will go th file take  that piece off the board so I think he  has resigned yeah  it's over Lavon aronian is knocked out  of the Julius bear generation cup after  a very nice and entertaining fight